[Musique]
je ressens
bonjour jean louis bourlanges bonjour
bienvenue dans le studio d'europe 1 vous
êtes président de la commission des
affaires étrangères de l'assemblée
nationale alors jean louis bourlanges
jusqu'à hier on se demandait ce qu'il
pouvait bien y avoir dans la tête de
vladimir poutine depuis hier matin et le
déclenchement de cette guerre en ukraine
et bien on est fixée finalement le chef
du kremlin prend sa revanche sur
l'histoire il reconstitue une partie de
l' empire soviétique oui enfin moi je
dois dire que ce qui s'est passé depuis
cette semaine me semble avoir été
prévisible mais abominable prévisible
parce que si poutine n'avait pas fait ce
qu'il a ce qu'il a fait c'est à dire
d'abord la déclaration de sécession puis
ensuite l'invasion de l'ukraine il
aurait perdu la faille aurait perdu la
partie il aurait perdu la partie le cren
ce sera entre est à à l'ouest
l'amérique à cause de lui à cause de lui
à cause de ces manoeuvres préalable donc
j'étais très inquiet et ça s'est produit
conformément aux pires prévisions
effectivement qu'est ce qu'il ya
derrière il y avait
il ya plusieurs choses il y avait
d'abord une prétendue menace sur la
sécurité je crois que c'est une vaste
blague l'idée que les états unis qui
n'avaient d'yeux que pour le pacifique
et est menacée à travers l'alliance
atlantique la russie ça n'était pas
sérieux l'usd yen ne serait jamais
entrée dans l'otan et l'idée que l'union
non mais et ça c'était dans en tout cas
à discuter on a refusé à bale notamment
les français les allemands se sont
opposés à bush john yoo ans à bucarest
en 2008 c'était on était évidemment
pourquoi on a refusé pourquoi on a on
était qu'on n'était pas favorable à ce
que le cren rendant le temps parce que
l'ukraine c est est supposé être un pays
frère de la russie il s'était séparé
tous à l'amiable sans qu'on ait pris
aucune part à cela en revanche on a fait
rentrer tous les pays qui avaient été
asservis par les russes donc l'avait pas
de problème de sécurité n'est pas le
récit deuxièmement il ya eu le problème
de la contagion démocratique
on voit bien que c'est maidan d'un côté
l'association avec l'union européenne
c'est-à-dire l'idée que l'ukraine
pourrait à terme offrir un modèle un peu
comparable à la pologne alors que le
destin que lui destine poutine c'est
celui de la biélorussie bon ça c'est
qu'on compensera mais maintenant ce
qu'on voit c'est effectivement c'est
votre question posa le problème dans sa
vraie dimension on voit que poutine est
engagé dans un processus dont il avait
lui-même dit qu'il était absurde il ya
quelques années celui qui regrette
l'union si l'union soviétique la pâte
est
il est engagé dans un processus de
reconstitution de lempire profitant du
fait que les américains sont flageolant
les européens sont toujours des chats
domestiques est toujours aussi peu un
tigre du bengale donc c'est très il ya
une faiblesse donc et je crois que
poutine ira je crois que la formule qui
a été donné par un athéisme paraît juste
poutine ne s'arrêtera que quand on
l'arrêtera donc c'est ça le problème est
comment mais là on va pas l'arrêter en
ukraine 2 ans en ukraine je crois hélas
que le problème militaire sera réglée au
profit de monsieur poutine dans un délai
rapide mais ne croyons pas que c'est
terminé ne croyons pas que il n'y aura
pas de menace sur les les baltes les
pays baltes oui enfin laisser le poutine
a déclaré david salanon néron on est je
suis très inquiet depuis le début sur la
moldavie
poutine a montré qu'ils considéraient
les valeurs comme nuls et non avenus les
engagements internationaux comme des
chiffons de papier
l'otan ne lui fera peur que si le temps
a les moyens de protéger c'est ses
membres donc ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui
on est pieds et poings liés on va faire
des sanctions mais je vois d'ailleurs qu
on hésite un peu à faire des sanctions
massives en parler mais de toute manière
il faut maintenant qu'on repense
complètement nos logiciels et qu'on se
met dans une position d'être un nouveau
fort de pouvoir protéger les membres de
l'otan ça implique ce que d'ailleurs le
président la république française
l'envoi de ronde depuis le nombre mois
on se mobilise au 5 en europe pour
renforcer le pilier européen de
l'alliance et avec avait donc à
commencer par ses troupes les premières
troupes des renforts français que la
france renvoie ici vous allez me dire
c'est symbolique mais voit ça c'est un
truc symbolique en matière médicale fin
et le faire mais ce que je crois très
profondément que 1 où on a changé de
périole a changé d'époque que maintenant
si nous ne comprenons pas en france en
allemagne en allemagne surtout en europe
et aux états unis que l'histoire est
extrêmement menaçante pour nous si nous
ne reconnut ne changeons pas notre
logiciel si nous ne consacrons pas aux
affaires militaires des moyens plus
importants si nous ne muscles ont pas
nos stratégies c'est il faut changer de
logique nous sommes nous ne sommes pas
sortis de l'épisode bizounours de la
guerre de la guerre froide gagner on a
dit nos valeurs triomphe et cetera non
maintenant c'est sérieux ce que nous
sommes profondément est menacé par
poutine alors en attendant en attendant
jean-louis bourlanges on en est au stade
des sanctions économiques qualifiée de
massive dans le secteur de l'énergie de
la finance et transport est ce qu'elles
vont avoir des effets sur le vladimir
poutine rappelons que les vingt-sept
n'ont pas choisi par exemple d'exclure
la russie vous savez du du fameux
système bijoux istin le système des
changes bancaire international oui
d'abord moi mais les sanctions je crois
qu'elles sont nécessaires parce que ya
aucune raison de ne pas punir les
malfaiteurs mais je ne crois pas qu'on
arrête une guerre avec des sanctions
quel est alors que je suis incapable de
détailler devant vous les sanctions qui
sont bonne mauvaise et tu sais c'est du
travail de découpage décision et je
prierai mais il est certain que les
sanctions c'est une arme ambivalente
parce que nos économies sont
profondément teinte interdépendantes et
que quand on fait des sanctions eh bien
on en subit aussi pour une part un
préjudice moi je crois à l'importance
des sanctions personnes anti personnel
c'est-à-dire directement visées sur
vladimir poutine son entourage les
oligarques
je crois qu'il faut aller très loin par
exemple c'est pas simplement limité
enfin c'est mon opinion je suis je suis
pas à la table de de la discussion pour
savoir exactement ce qu'il faut faire
mais par exemple et les visas on a
toutes ces vies la splendide déjà liga
il faut les il faut les prendre les
capitaux à la ciel de londres je suis
toujours étonné les capitaux bien sûr
enfin seuls les capacités de voyage les
capacités les propriétés de tous ces
gens doivent êtres prises juste toujours
étonné que il ya une espèce de
d'immunité accordée au chef suprême je
crois pas en règle en bon procès on
punit pas les complices
peu plus sévèrement que l'auteur
principal cerveau est effectivement
weeks et il ya quelque chose de bon
alors tout ça doit être discuté je sens
quand même une assez grande difficulté à
se mettre entièrement d'accord sur sur
le détail compte tenu des retombées donc
les sanctions il faut les faire il faut
qu'elle soit sévère il faut qu'elle soit
antipersonnel mais il faut bien voir que
notre la solution pour nous notre c'est
pas ça aujourd'hui on ne peut pas faire
grand chose à long terme on doit tout
faire pour inverser le rapport de force
pour nous mettre dans une situation on a
les moyens on a quand même un pib qui
est huit fois supérieur à celui de la
russie on a on a de l'intelligence on a
des de la technologie on a de
l'innovation on peut il suffit de
vouloir de se mobiliser c'est ça le
problème vous avez dire beaucoup de
responsables politiques qui sont au fait
des questions internationales que
finalement vladimir poutine nous
comprend que la force mais est-ce que la
force des occidentaux états unis et
europe réunit sera suffisante en tout
cas on a intérêt à augmenter parce que
pour l'instant ce qu'on voit c'est que
les états unis ont été assez flageolant
comme alliée au cours des dix dernières
années on a vu quand même les
hésitations de monsieur obama la franche
hostilité de monsieur trump à l'égard de
l'europe occidentale et notamment de
l'allemagne et on a vu quand même des
incertitudes et des mouvements de
monsieur byden notamment nous en avons
nous en avons subi la conséquence avec
la crise des sous marins australiens on
a vu le retour d'afghanistan et poutine
a profité de toussaint tous eu
oui enfin il ay là il a profité du fait
poutine savais pas ce que le cren
n'était pas dans le temps que de toute
manière il n'y aurait pas d'intervention
il n'y avait pas d' article 5 de
solidarité et qu'il n'y aurait pas
d'intervention militaire donc voila
c'était de ce point de vue là c'était
prévisible et on pouvait pas faire
rentrer non plus on n'improvise pas
l'entrée de l'ukraine dans le temps on
n'improvise pas une guerre sauf si on a
envie de la perdre
faut-il d'ores et déjà jean louis
bourlanges que les pays d'europe
occidentale se prépare à l'accueil de
réfugiés ukrainien qui vont fuir le joug
russe oui je crois que je crois que
c'est une qu'il y aura des mouvements je
ne sais pas de quelle ampleur pour des
raisons là aussi politique très claire
c'est que monsieur poutine aura intérêt
à ce qu'il y ait des mouvements pour
deux raisons pour se débarrasser
d'opposants potentiel dans son pays et
v6 et à l'extérieur ils ne gêneront pas
et pour nous embarrasser nous mêmes
sachant que les flux migratoires comme
exactement comme luca tchenko à fait à
la frontière de la biélorussie la
pologne cesse et c'est la même technique
donc on va avoir et les nos amis
polonais s'apprête à recevoir des flots
d flot massif les hongrois ont pu ces
endroits c'est une situation compliquée
parce qu'il n'était pas en très très
bons rapports avec les ukrainiens parce
que les mesures anti russophone amoureux
sans doute excessive d'ailleurs prise
par l'ukraine se traduisait par des
mesures anti un gars au flanc il faut il
ya une minorité hongroise en ukraine qui
était un peu ça sorbonne il est quand
même très très clairs sur la défense des
droits culturels africains il faut
prévoir si ce n'est craindre un flux
afflux migratoire il faut dans le sens
il faut le prévoir ce sera sans doute
une immigration de grande qualité en
revanche ce sont des intellectuels pas
seulement mais on aura une immigration
de grande qualité dont on pourra tirer
profit petit regard sur l'intérieur de
la russie vous dit vous avez dit que
poutine est en quelque sorte un
dictateur aux abois qui n'a trouvé que
cette invasion pour satisfaire son
opinion publique au delà des des projets
politiques qu'on que l'on évoqué tout à
l'heure mais justement est ce que les
russes sont aussi soudé que cela
derrière leur leur président il semble
pas non je crois d'ailleurs cic
il ya un très bon portrait de par votre
consoeur leur mondeville dans le figaro
ce matin que ses ventes le portait de
poutine qui montre bien qu'ils règlent
d'abord son compte avec lui-même c'est
un stade qui est dangereux on voit que
ce qui remet en cause c'est tout ce qui
s'est fait depuis depuis la chute du mur
de berlin en réalité moi j'ai le
sentiment françois bayroux me disait au
téléphone cette nuit il me disait je
pense que c'est un attentat contre les
deux peuples et c'est très juste c'est
un attentat contre le peuple ukrainien
qui est quand même un peuple frère du
peuple russe il faut moi je prenais gdg
un filleul qui est à moitié à kate
ukrainien qui travaillent à moscou etc
tous les russes les ukrainiens de la
famille ouvrière et les russes
ressemblaient les russes n'ont pas envie
de cette affaire bien sûr la gloire le
nationalisme la fièvre etc l'hymne de
l'hymne russe et sert à l'ailé russe
vibre à ça mais au-delà de ça je pense
pas je pense qu'ils veulent manger ils
veulent être chauffée ils veulent avoir
des promotions ils veulent acquérir le
la liberté ils ont ils ont des besoins
qui sont les besoins des peuples
occidentaux encore quelques mots jean
louis bourlanges on aurait peut être dû
en parler avant et la chine la chine
dans tout ça elle n'a pas vraiment
condamner l'entreprise guerrière de
poutine est ce que ce n'est pas elle
finalement qui pourrait le stopper pla
del mir poutine qu'elle n'a pas
forcément intérêt une déstabilisation au
coeur de l'europe la chine dont la chine
je dois dire que moi je l'avais vu je
leur ai pensé plus solidaire encore de
poutine pour l'instant elle alain un jeu
parfait elle ne donne elle dit c'est la
faute des états unis s'est toujours
c'est toujours bon à prendre comme
accusation et elle se garde bien de
d'agir à mon avis elle tire les marrons
du feu la chine sait et c'est dix fois
la population de la russie j'ai un ami
qui avait appris récemment le train qui
avait le moscou à pékin 17 absolument
frappant quand on est en russie c'est
tout est pourri rouillé etc ont franchi
la frontière tout est moderne tout est
neuf et récemment on disait que monsieur
xi avait regardé une grande carte de la
sibérie et avait dit pensif
c'est très vide effectivement c'est
assez inquiétant sadi pour monsieur
poutine je crois effectivement c'est lui
le bénéficiaire est ce qu il en
profitera pour faire un coup son taiwan
jeu l'inquiétude et je pense que je
pense que la tentation est grande parce
que vraiment les chinois sont décidés
très typé
situation web hayden les chinois ne
peuvent pas ignorer que ce serait
vraiment la guerre et parce que ben hida
ne peut pas reculer une fois de plus il
y aurait vis-à-vis de taiwan une
réaction des états unis qui n'est pas
celle qui lie actuellement par rapport à
l'économie peuvent après l'afghanistan
après ce qui se passe en ukraine
les etats unis sont finis s'il laisse
prendre taïwan ça les chinois le savent
mais malgré tout la situation est
extrêmement précaire merci jean louis
bourlanges merci d'être passé dans les
studios d'europe 1 ce matin un président
de la commission des affaires étrangères
à l'assemblée nationale merci